what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain every attack titan in
the history of attack on titan
this shifter was by far the most
requested and it's not hard to see why
because it is essentially the main titan
of the show not only is it possessed by
aaron who is the main character
but this titan has historically been
held by people who are rebellious
and always seeking freedom as usual i'll
be explaining the backstory of all
attack titans that we know
as well as commenting on the designs of
the previous attack titans throughout
history
but before we get into it there are a
couple things i want to mention first
number one is that for those who might
not be aware the original japanese title
for attack on titan is shingeki no
kyojin
and when aaron revealed the name of his
titan in episode 58
it was also shingeki no kyojin this
means that while other titans might have
episodes named after them here or there
there is clearly one titan that stands
above them all
as you know like i said the entire
series is named after it
the next thing i wanted to mention
relates to the great titan war and it's
just another example of why the attack
titan is so special
according to willie tiber the great
titan war occurred over a hundred years
before the series began
and at that time the founding titan was
held by the royal family
and the remaining eight titans including
the attack titan were held by noble
families
king fritz then fled to paradise island
with his founding titan and the tigers
were the ones who were left in control
of mali
the tigers then enabled mali to steal
the remaining shifters from the other
noble families with the attack titan
being the only one
that managed to avoid being taken for a
long while it was unclear how this titan
managed to stay out of mali's hands
while the others were taken
but thanks to chapter 122 of the manga
we now know why
spoiler warning ahead for any anime only
viewers as in order to properly explain
this titan
i will be talking about manga spoilers
from this point onwards
anyway as i was saying the reason the
attack titan was able to evade capture
was due to its special ability
and this is called future memory
inheritance this is an insane power that
enables the inheritor
to see memories of both past and future
users of the attack titan
grisha jaeger described it as the
ability to know the future and we first
saw this power on display during season
three
just before aaron krueger passed on the
power to grisha he told him that if he
wants to save armin mikasa and everyone
else
then he must see his plan through till
the end the obvious problem here is that
ahmed and mikasa were literally not even
born when kruger said this
meaning that the memory that triggered
him to say those words must have come
from the future
the memory that kruger briefly saw was
likely this moment when grisha was
passing on the titan to aaron
because in that scene grisham said those
exact same words
with that said though it's time to
explain the backstory of every attack
titan
and then when we get to erin i'll be
explaining how he used the future memory
inheritance to influence the past
if you haven't already then be sure to
hit that sub button and let me know in
the comments which titan you think i
should do next
okay so the first attack titan on this
list is aaron kruger and i consider his
backstory to be equally as important as
the jaegers
because he laid the foundations for
everything that happened before kruger
was born
they were still members of the fritz
royal family who had been left behind in
mali
and those royal members created the
first group of elden restorationists
kruger's father decided to join that
restorationist group with aaron himself
being just a regular elden child who was
born in mali
we know from his memory that he lived
with his parents and had a little sister
but around the age of 10 years old the
mayan authorities discovered the
restorationist group
and burned the kruger family alive on
that day aaron managed to avoid being
set on fire as he was hiding in the
closet
so the marine authorities didn't
actually know he was in the house he
watched on through a crack in the closet
door as his family were killed
but just before the house burnt down he
was saved by one of his father's friends
this event fostered kruger's
immeasurable hatred towards mali
and he swore that one day he would get
revenge and restore elder like his
father failed to do
the first step in his plan would begin
years later when he met a doctor living
in mali
who was secretly an aldian we never saw
the doctor on screen
but he was the one that helped kruger to
falsify his medical records
and in the process aaron was able to
pretend to be amalian
he used his new malian status to join
the public security authorities
which is the same organization that
killed his family the reason he did this
would become more obvious as we continue
but to summarize it kruger joined the
authorities because it gave him special
privileges that he knew would one day
help to secure ld's freedom
it goes without saying that only marlins
can join the organization so his fake
medical records were 100 necessary
and once he was in he then had to avoid
suspicion of course the best way to
blend in with the other offices is to do
what they do
so over the years aaron would devote
himself to being as ruthless towards
aldians
as his other malian comrades throughout
his career he tortured thousands of
eldians and turned many of them into
pure titans on parodies islands
in the year 817 grisha and faye jaeger
left the liberia internment zone to try
and see the airship
but kruger noticed them and asked for
their exit permits all
eldians leaving the walls need to have a
permit but on this day neither grisha or
faye had the relevant paperwork
in keeping with his undercover act aaron
proceeded to give grisha a punishment on
behalf of both siblings
while faye was taken away by his
colleague that colleague would go on to
have faye torn apart by dogs
and her body would be discovered in the
river the next day we know from kruger's
words 15 years later
that he did feel some guilt for calling
out to grisha in the first place
but regardless he still continued to
pose as amalian and rise up the ranks
two years after that incident kruger
would then inherit the attack titan from
an unknown individual
and although we don't know his
predecessor it's easy to see why they
would choose him
whoever had the attack titan must have
known that krug would be the one to make
the restorationist rise again
because that's exactly what he did using
an alias known as the owl
aaron founded a new underground
restorationist movement with lds being
recruited all across liberia
given that kruger worked within the
marlin authorities he had access to
secret information that he would filter
down to the restorationists with one
example being the true reason why marley
wanted to invade paradise
the owl also provided them with money
weapons and historical documents
but his identity was always kept a
secret on one occasion he sent grace to
recruit grisha to the organization
and this was a very smart move because
grisha would end up becoming the second
in command
additionally kruger discovered the last
remaining member of the fritz royal
family living in mali
and sent her to join the restorationists
as well diner fritz had a ton of new
information that benefited the group
and of course her and grisham would then
fall in love and have a son called zeke
because kruger had a high ranking
position within mali at this point
he planned to use his authority to pull
some strings and ensure zeke became a
warrior
however the kid was such a bad candidate
that even kruger wasn't able to
intervene
one interesting thing to note is that
kruger said his goal was to boost the
morale of the restorationist
so as a result there was a lot of things
he didn't tell them one example is the
fact that he never told them that zeke
would only have 13 years left to live
if their plan to make him a warrior was
successful moving on to the design of
kruger's titan
it has the same height and physique as
the other attack titans we've seen
with its most distinctive feature being
its hollow eyes it is crazy to think
that in the 13 years he had this power
this right here is likely the only time
he actually used it because i mean when
he was in mali i doubt there was ever a
scenario when he actually had to do this
the next attack titan is grisha jaeger
and although we've already covered some
of his backstory
there are still many details that i
didn't mention to begin
grisha was born in the liberia
internment zone where his father worked
as a doctor and as we know
he had a younger sister named faye the
day after faye was killed by malia
authorities
the officer that had her killed
pretended as if he didn't know what
happened grisha always suspected that
the man knew more than what he said
but by contrast his parents just
accepted the story they were told
this is because his parents were
basically afraid and they didn't want to
risk asking more questions
because that in turn could get their
family in trouble grisha's father would
constantly try to indoctrinate his son
with malian propaganda
in the hope that grisha would become
less rebellious and just accept a quiet
life within the wars of liberia
over time grisha reluctantly came to
accept that the world was just an unfair
place
and at 18 years old he was going through
the motions one day planning to take
over his father's medical practice
that was of course until aaron kruger
sent someone to speak to him and that
person had information about
faye's death like i said grisha had
always suspected that his sister's death
was suspicious
and because aaron kruger was colleagues
with the guy that killed her he had
known the truth for a long time
when grisha really found out what
happened to faye he was immediately
radicalized and vowed to destroy mali
and restore the alien empire
when dynafritz joined the group it was
grisha that suggested the plan to take
the founding titan from paradise and
return it to the true royal family
grisha didn't consider the royals and
parodies to be true royals because they
had left so many aliens behind
after dinah and grisha had zeke he made
the terrible mistake of treating the boy
as a tool
rather than his actual son and he was so
focused on the goal of restoring elder
that he never made time to be a real
father
by indoctrinating zeke to become the
savior of elder grisha inadvertently
made the same mistake that his own
father did
and paid the price by being sent to
paradise having then received the power
of the attack titan
grisha was able to run towards the walls
and was eventually picked up by keith
shadis who at the time was a young
member of the survey corps
grisha acted like he remembered nothing
besides his name and occupation
and used keith as someone who could
teach him about how things work on
parodies
through their friendship he eventually
met a waitress named carla and sometime
after this
grisha would use his skills as a doctor
to save both carla and her parents
the two of them would eventually get
married and have a son and grisham would
name this child aaron to pay respects to
the man that got him here in the first
place
despite his lingering mission to take
the founding titan grisham made sure not
to repeat the same mistakes he made with
zeke
and he spent quality time with aaron
whenever he had the chance allowing the
child to just be himself
as his status as a doctor continued to
grow grisham was given more and more
high-profile clients to take care of
which in time got him closer to the
royal family on one occasion he treated
a noble living on the island
and when that person was asleep grisham
stole a document that led to the rice
chapel
the rice chapel is where the royal
family go to pass the founding titan
and with this address grisha could
finally fulfill the goal of the
restorationists
nevertheless it wasn't until many years
later that he would steal the founding
titan
as he valued the new family he had built
and didn't want to risk losing them
although he did go to visit the rice
chapel soon after he found the address
he chose not to confront the royal
family and didn't return until the day
the wars were destroyed
on that note we should probably talk
about the design of his attack titan
as it was shown to have a few
interesting features grisha's
distinctive elf ears are nearly
identical to both zeke and eren's titans
which makes this a nice hereditary
feature of the jaeger family
his titan body is slightly wider and
less lean than kruger's version
not to mention that he also has titan
chest hair and raggedy looking hair on
his head
much like kruger grisha had very few
opportunities to actually use this titan
and i'm pretty sure overall he used it
twice the first time being when he ran
to the walls
and the second time being in the rice
chapel now moving on to erin yeager
instead of talking about his backstory
i'm gonna be breaking down how he used
future memory inheritance to influence
the past
this was undoubtedly one of the most
confusing sequences in the entire series
so i'm going to try and explain it as
best i can but you know it is still
pretty complicated to start things off
we should establish a few essential
rules
with the first rule being that with the
power of future memory inheritance
grisha is sometimes able to see aaron's
memories from the future
once christian sees those future
memories then much like any other person
it would affect his present day actions
in some way rule number two is that
aaron is likely able to choose which
memories his father sees
which means that eren can use these
memories to manipulate his father's
actions in the past
this is something that zeke speculates
in the manga and aaron does not deny
doing this
the final rule is that thanks to the
power of the founding titan both zeke
and aaron were able to wander through
grisha's memories however
they are just witnesses and they are not
able to interact with the past
this part is so important that i need to
stress it again aaron and zeke are
essentially ghosts who are just
witnessing past memories
but they are not able to interact with
those memories all they can do is see it
on the day that grisham really went to
steal the founding titan he entered the
rice chapel and begged for the rice
to save the people of paradise because
of the vow announcing war
frida refused his request with grisha
then making a move to steal the founding
titan
as he goes to transform krishna
hesitates because he can't bring himself
to massacre the royal family
and it's important to remember that at
this point grisha had never killed a
person in his life
this is the moment when aaron's biggest
interference occurs and he uses future
memory inheritance to do this
aaron tells his father to stand and as i
mentioned aaron is essentially a ghost
so grisha should not be able to see or
hear him in this moment however grisha
can clearly hear him so i'm going to use
a quick comparison to explain how this
happened
imagine that someone from the future is
secretly observing you right now
but you can't see them and you can't
hear what they're saying now
if you had future memory inheritance you
could observe the memories of that
person who was watching you
as a result of looking at those memories
of them looking at you you would hear
what they said to you when ordinarily
you were not able to
according to the second rule i mentioned
aaron could choose which memories he
wanted his father to see
and right now as he was speaking to
grisha he was simultaneously sending
that memory back to grisha
during the same moment in the past in
summary in case that was confusing
while grisha was hesitating to kill the
royal family he was also at the same
time
witnessing the memories that erin was
sending back this enabled grisha to
experience this moment
from both his own perspective and his
son's perspective and by doing that it
allowed him to hear what aaron was
saying
grisha heard eren's words motivating him
to do what needed to be done
and this resulted in the slaughter of
the rice family and obviously the theft
of the founding titan
without interference it's likely that
grisham would never have taken the
founding titan
so this is a paradox that exists within
the world of attack on titan
but i love this type of thing i mean if
any of you have seen my backup time
travel theory
this is pretty cool to me in the other
moments when aaron is sending memories
back to grisha
you'll notice how grisha is literally
seeing things through aaron's eyes
for example in this scene aaron is
staring directly at zeke
and then grisha wakes up because he
briefly saw this older version of zeke
that erin was looking at
anyway with time travel explained let's
move on to aaron's titan design
and the other attack titans throughout
history from the beginning erin's titan
has been very athletic
standing at 15 meters tall and having a
lean muscular physique
unlike his predecessors he has a wide
jagged mouth that is only good for
screaming
with his tongue looking very devilish
his pointy ears are something that he
has in common with his father
but other than that there aren't too
many similarities between them
the ancient attack titans are next up
and while we don't know which era these
titans are from
it's still interesting to have a look
these first two were seen during the
final arc of attack on titan
with one of them having hollow eyes
comparable to aaron kruger but a mouth
similar to eren yeager
the titan next to him is the chad attack
titan and as far as i can tell he's the
only one to have chest hair besides
grisha
in addition to them it's highly likely
that this titan here was the first
attack titan
with its defining feature being its
weird looking mouth we saw the bald
attack titan in a different panel
who had a slightly less muscular body
than usual and again had hollow eyes
like many of the other titans
the balding attack titan also made an
appearance in the series and unlike the
last guy
he hadn't lost all of his hair just yet
any remaining shifters had very brief
background appearances
but i'm still pretty sure they're attack
titans given that they seem to be the
correct height and have the right
physique with that said
thank you for watching this video about
all the titans in history and be sure to
let me know which one you think i should
do next
until the next video peace out